-Here at "Late Night," every
night, I deliver a monologue
made up of jokes written
by a diverse team of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk that,
due to my being
a straight while male,
would be difficult
for me to deliver.
But we don't stop -- we don't
think that should stop you
from enjoying them, so
we'd like to share them
with you now in a segment
called "Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪
Hey, everybody.
These are two of our writers,
Amber and Jenny.
-I'm Black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not,
so I'll read the set-ups
for these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go.
According to "Men's Journal,"
the best dating app
for gay men is eHarmony.
-While the best for lesbians
is TaskRabbit.
-The city of Birmingham,
Alabama,
has seen a population growth
recently in white neighborhoods.
-White neighborhoods --
or as they're more
commonly known,
former Black neighborhoods.
-A new viral TikTok trend
features users
posting checklists to help women
figure out if they're lesbians.
-The checklist
has one question --
are your keys on one of these?
-Is that really
where you keep your keys?
-Yes, and then I hang this from
the belt loop of my pants.
-And what if
you're wearing a skirt?
[ Laughter ]
Can you imagine?
What would that even look like?
-I don't know. Good one, bud.
-[ Sighs ]
Serena Williams
was recently spotted
taking a carriage ride
through Central Park.
-Even crazier, the chair umpire
gave her a penalty for it.
-Amber, have you ever taken a
carriage ride in Central Park?
-No! I'm not going to pay 60
bucks to smell horse [bleep]
when the subway is only $2.75.
-Two teammates on
the WMBA's Connecticut Suns
recently got engaged
to each other.
-They met at the start
of the first quarter.
-Okay. So now, Jenny, this comes
up a lot in this segment.
Do lesbians really commit
that fast?
-Let me put it this way.
If you were a lesbian,
we would have gotten married
halfway through my first day.
-Jenny! So nice.
-Yeah.
A park in Texas will be named
after the city's
first Black police officer.
-It's called
Mixed Feelings Park.
-The "Huffington Post"
recently posted an article
about the dangers of
wearing a ponytail holder
around your wrist.
-A ponytail holder
around your wrist --
or as lesbians call it,
fine jewelry.
-Jenny, do you keep a spare
ponytail holder on your wrist?
-Absolutely not.
I keep it on my key chain.
-Oh. There we go.
The Met is opening its first
opera written by a Black person.
-Which explains
why it starts with a skit.
Seth, did you get that joke?
-I did.
-Jenny, did you get that joke?
-I...did not.
-Well, that's a better hit rate
than it will have
in the real world.
-I like that it went
as exactly as well
as if we had a full [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
Two queer women in Brooklyn
have launched
a new craft beer
called Dyke Beer.
-Because the name Busch
was already taken.
[ Can top popping ]
-Sorry. What was that?
-That's a lesbian mating call.
-Ah.
According to CBS News,
there's a trend of Black
Americans leaving the U.S.
and moving to Ghana.
-"Just a suggestion,"
said my landlord.
-Hey, Seth,
why don't you tell one?
-Oh, guys,
I don't think I could.
-Buddy, you've got to.
Just tell one.
-Alright, but I don't feel like
this is going to end well.
-Oh, come on. Do it.
-Okay. Okay.
After being fired at the host of
"The Bachelor,"
Chris Harrison recently received
an eight-figure settlement,
but it's "The Bachelor," so even
though it was eight figure,
it only had a four face.
-Seth, no!
-Amber, yes!
Jenny, yes.
-Seth, no!
-I will die on that hill.
-That's inappropriate.
-We'll try again.
A big-cat sanctuary in England
recently announced the birth
of a rare black jaguar cub.
"What a shame for the family,"
said Prince Charles.
-How dare you?!
-You told me it would be okay.
-You should be ashamed!
The audience would be ashamed
if they were here,
but they're not.
-Black women and lesbians
are liars.
♪♪